What are incubators and accelerators and
how can they help your startup?
Incubators and accelerators are programs
meant to speed up the growth and
success of startups.
They provide resources for
your idea and give you the focus and
direction necessary to gain some
traction for your business.
Think of them basically like how
an incubator works for an egg.
The egg, like your idea, already exists,
but it's the resources and
careful nurturing of it that allow
it to grow into its new environment.
Let's take a look at some of the
benefits of working with incubators and
accelerators.
The main benefits you'll get in these
programs are networking and services.
First, networking, incubators and
accelerators provide a ton of
opportunities for networking between
you, other entrepreneurs, and
coaches that are part of the program.
This can help you gain the foundation
you need to mature as a business.
Next, services, the connections you
get often extend beyond coaches,
into networks you can use to
get funding, services, and
mentorship, which can be an invaluable
asset to the growth of your startup.
If you don't currently have a strong
network or don't know where to
get the skills you need,
this can be a great place to start.
So those are some of the benefits but
what are some of the downsides.
Here's two focus and equity.
First while all this guidance and
networking can be an incredible
experience, this can make it difficult
to focus on your business and
give it the attention it
needs to grow effectively.
Make sure to find the balance between
meeting people to talk about your
business and actually building it.
Next equity, both incubators and
accelerators are meant to jumpstart your
business and
what they want in return is equity.
You're likely to get a substantial
amount of equity in return for
your experience.
If your business takes off,
this could become very costly later on.
You'll need to be sure the value
you're getting is worth the value
you're giving up.
If you have strong connections or
are growing quickly already,
then these programs might not provide
the right value for you moving forward.
There are tons of incubators and
accelerators to choose from and
none of them are quite the same.
So it's difficult to gauge how effective
they could be for your business.
Explore different options and
take some time to consider if you think
incubators or accelerators could
be right for your business.